how's it going everybody it's Warren and
there's a lot of talk right now about
when we can expect the next Avengers
in-game trailer and new footage since we
got new footage of Avengers endgame at
the Superbowl people have been wondering
when the next official trailer will drop
and right now there's a rumor going
around about when to expect it that has
a lot of backing behind it so in case it
ends up being true I'll tell you
everything you need to know also a quick
reminder that I started a new giveaway
if you'd like to enter for your chance
to win five imax tickets so you and some
friends can go see Captain Marvel or
Avengers in-game in IMAX all you have to
do is subscribe to my channel with the
notifications turned on like the video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
your favorite villain so right now it is
rumoured and believed by many that the
next trailer for Avengers in-game will
premiere during the 91st Academy Awards
ceremony on February 24th now many
people have been speculating this for a
while but there actually is some solid
backing behind this prediction Marvel
Studios will already have a very large
presence at the Academy Awards with
Black Panther being nominated seven
times for seven different Awards
including Best Picture which makes Black
Panther the first-ever comic book movie
to earn an Academy Award nomination so
they already have a very large presence
there another thing is that the Academy
Awards premiere on ABC well Disney owns
ABC so it makes sense that they would
promote Avengers end game and it would
be a win-win for Disney if they did air
a new trailer for Avengers in game
during the awards the ratings for the
Oscars have been declining over time so
announcing that there will be new
footage for Avengers in game will
definitely help with the ratings and
even though the ratings for the Oscars
have been declining millions of people
still watch the Oscars that would mean
millions of people who enjoy movies
would be watching new footage for
Avengers end game so it would make sense
for Disney to premiere new footage for
Avengers in game during the Oscars
because it would be a win-win for them
it would be good for the Oscars ratings
and it would be good for the movie again
this is just a rumor for right now if I
hear anything official about this I'll
be sure to let you know the Oscars are
only 11 days away so if this does become
official they will definitely do an
announcement a few days before so if we
do end up getting new footage
Avengers in game soon let me know what
you are most excited to see let me know
in the comments down below and again
don't forget to subscribe with the
notifications turned on comment down
below and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
on everything relating to Avengers
endgame as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof
[Music]